we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two David P Gavin
McInnes is one of the founders of a
extremist right-wing group called the
proud boys he has a new program that
program is advertising on YouTube
interestingly and here's a voicemail I
got pointing out a very strange double
standard take a listen
hey David the stylist from Alexandra
Virginia column because I was just
watching YouTube and I saw an ad for a
Gavin mcginnises show and was just
completely shocked that with all the DES
monetization going on that someone like
him is
allowed to advertise YouTube clearly
doesn't care anymore about what contents
accessible to make money also and just
want to say I've been a member since
2016 and anyone who values the work you
do should pitch in any way they can so
you can completely stop depending on
YouTube thanks for the work you do have
a good one
thank you and it is stunning right
YouTube is really scared about putting
ads on content that is supposedly not
brand safe including D monetizing a
video of mine where I displayed clips
from a Donald Trump press conference and
meanwhile the completely not brand safe
Gavin McGinnis who founded an extremist
group named the proud boys is actually
part of YouTube's advertising program
and is running ads on YouTube it's
backwards okay and the solution is to
separate content and advertising make
programs that you like independent of ad
revenue whether it's the David Pakman
show or others that's your call to make
very very disturbing reality is what's
going on we've got a great bonus show
for you today one of the many member
benefits hope to talk to you then